zum ersten Mal heißt es bei klicksom
Community und das heißt ihr seid dran
und zwar nicht nur mit videofragen
sondern auch mit euren Kommentaren unter
dem fragideo an alpagan die er jetzt
beantworten wird unter anderem mit Infos
zu seinem Beef mit farahid Bang da gibt
es neue Infos und natürlich noch viel
mehr also bis dann bleib
dran biobonat fragt ich glaube das
Niveau der Kommentare wird es steigen
wenn du weniger Rapper einlädst
mein Homie ich bin kein Rapper ich bin
Schauspieler und Entertainer ja ist ein
riesen Unterschied Künstler Habbi g
Prince Wolfsburg fragt hey Alpa welches
Shampoo benutzt du es gibt nur ein Prinz
und das ist Kevin Prinz Beng und weil
ich so viele Haare habe benutze ich
alpzin wenn du verstehst was ich meine
alpazin alpazin hört sich besser an mein
eigener Produkt man mit dir kommen ins
Geschäft hi Alan meine Fragen an dich
sind wie sich der Beef mit dir und far
sich in letzte Zeit entwickelt hat wie
es mit Farah angefangen hat das war eine
beef Geschichte zwischen Sido und eo
Farid ist eo sein wow wow und ich bin
sido sein Mann und wir beide sind heute
im Ring und die beiden haben sich
versöhnt also so hat es sich entwickelt
was noch passiert der liebe Gott weiß es
aus welcher Stadt du kamst also aus der
Türkei aus welcher Stadt ich aus der
Türkei komme das ist dir egal es tut mir
leid es ist euch egal denn in der Türkei
will ich meine Ruhe haben danke schön
und für welche türkische fußballschaft
ich bin Fußballfan gewesen aber jetzt
bin
ich nur für die Mannschaft die in der
Türkei gewinnt ja sprich wenn faner
gewinnt bin ich für faner wenn Galata
gewinnt bin ich für Galata weil ich habe
keine Lust diese türkischen Ausdrücke in
mir reinzuziehen weißt du die sich
gegenseitig beleidigen und ein wahrer
Jerome borteng und Kevin Prinz Beng
Prinz Kevin borteng Fan ja z007 fragt
Alp was glaubst Du wann grong
kommt wenn der Mond mein Ghetto
kracht von wegen krachten oder was ja
wenn der Mund mein Ghetto krachten Mr
komy Freak meine Frage an alpagan
spielst du gerne mit
Waffen wahrscheinlich so wie hafffe so
gasnikoff oder was hat was hat der
Bazooka mit dies Spielzeugwaffen habe
ich nichts zu tun ich spiele ich bin
nicht der Meister aller Waffen ich bin
der Meister aller
Klassen nee meine Waffe sind meine
Wörter mein Homeboy ja das sind meine
Projektile meine Waffe und mein
sprachror ist mein sprachror
Rap jo alperagun mein Name ist Paul ich
habe drei Fragen an dich meine erste
Frage ist warum D und asrael nicht auf
ihren Sache drauf sind weil ich finde
die haben echt Talent und könen richtig
gut Rappen meine zweite Frage ist ob du
noch Beef mit fah hast weil ich habe im
Internet gelesen dass ihr euch Anblich
vertragen hab oder so meine dritte Frage
ist ob du vielleicht irgendwann noch ein
Feature mit F machast das wäich über
krass auf jeden Fall hat Sido und eo
beef haben beef gehabt Farid an EOS
Seite und ich an Sidos Seite und so ist
unser beef
entstanden fit hat sich bei mein Manager
gemeldet und wollte die Sache mit mir
öffentlich klären wir haben wie zwei
Männer also die haben wie zwei Männer
geredet wir haben abgemacht wie zwei
Männer dass er sich öffentlich dazu
äußert und sich entschuldigt und ich
hätte dasselbe gemacht ich mach das hier
auf jeden Fall ich entschuldige mich bei
seiner Mutter wirklich von Herzen das
was das was da passiert ist das war
nicht ehrenhaft weißt du ich bin ein
ehrenvoller Mensch und
da darum will ich mich hier noch mal bei
ihr persönlich entschuldigen und Farid
wollte das auch machen aber hatte ein
Interview bevor sein Album rauskam und
hat noch mal angerufen und hat mein
Manager noch mal mitgeteilt dass er sich
doch nicht dazu äußern will
ich weiß jetzt nicht wer jetzt sein Wort
gebrochen hat und wer nicht ich
entschuldige mich hier noch mal
persönlich bei seiner Mutter und ja ich
habe jetzt im Album noch mal zu Farid
gesagt was ich zu sagen habe und nach
meinem Album ist für mich die ganze
Sache mit Farid abgeschlossen hier noch
mal schöne Grüße an alle in Derendorf zu
Fahrt bestimmt von mir aus alles easy
könnte sein dass wir ein Feature machen
warum nicht ich bin cool mit fah schöne
Grüße von hier viel wichtiger ist dass
wir Menschen nicht miteinander klar
kommen als überhaupt als wenn wir ein
Feature machen aber könnte auch
passieren Paul Respekt dass du alle
meine CDs gekauft hast du bist Killer du
weißt Ehrensache am 27.4 albergan hat so
viele Fragen beantwort deswegen haben
wir noch ein zweites Community Video
gemacht das findet ihr hier außer guckt
genau am ersten oder zweiten Tag nach
dem Upload dieses Videos dann ist es
noch nicht verlinkt aber ansonsten da
könnt ihr mehr erfahren unter anderem zu
seinem Verhältnis mit Bushido und ein
anderes Community Video nenne ich es mal
so in eine nutzerfrage von Max Killer an
Farid Beng wo Farid Bang erklärt warum
obwohl er so ein super Fußballspieler
ist in dem Bereich nie sowas richtiges
aus ihm geworden ist es ist ein kleines
Detail also bis dann bleib
dran